hey guys how's it going so I am so
excited because right now we're at Heinz
Field and we're taking part in the
Steelers nation unite program now
anybody can do this all you have to do
is sign up Steelers nation unite calm or
you could even use the steelers app and
you can do all kinds of fun fan
experiences and we're gonna take you on
that little tour right now my whole
family is here I'm back in Pittsburgh I
actually cried well I found out we're
gonna get to do this so we're up here
and it's pretty much the most perfect
feeling the feels kind of
air-conditioned and I smell nice
everything we'd be on the field excuse
dealers
hello mister do you work out
do they want to put me in
oh my gosh I'm super moving I don't know
what to do I can like it's so big I can
put it on my wrist
oh my god unravel the terrible south
you're on the field pretty much ever
my guys lose the amazing game
unfortunately wasn't that amazing things
and Steelers lost but it's okay it's
still preseason and I'm super excited
for the action from the start I'm
actually really excited about fantasy
football this is my first time I've been
paying so much more attention to other
teams and their players up there he's
watching and let me know if you guys are
serious band in Austin let me know who
you are a fan up and career the third
make sure you check out the Steelers
nation of night because you guys have a
potential opportunity you do have this
experience looks great